[Music]
what shows do you watch so one of my
favorite shows is RuPaul's Drag Race you
say that tonight is the finale I know
I'm scared who are you rooting for I
think well I mean I really love all of
the girls you know that's so like pulasa
but okay I'm gonna tell you something I
really capitalized on Kennedy
Davenport's like monologue from season
seven when she was wearing that like
fire alpha when she said like after a
long night hook and trade didn't like
this session and then in that moment I
was like that's my president you know
what I mean
no absolutely um I love Trixie I mean
but and shangela has been so funny I'm
just such a huge huge fan could we ever
see you as a guest judge on the show I
mean I would love to do that yeah I have
a lot to say I believe that yeah I
believe it as well
house rule reached out yeah I'd be
surprised if you didn't well I think
that it would be so much it would be
really honestly I read our drink more no
I would die if I were able to do the
show um I mean everybody's asked like
are you gonna do the show would you be a
guest judge and I'm like I would
literally run into the middle of the 101
right now if I were able to make that
happen
don't do that we need you don't do that
please do I need that job you know what
you do need that job and you'd be
perfect for that job and I have a
feeling that job is coming up after a
long night of cooking tray
Jim like the fish and so here good at me
okay and sent me on fire oscy but you
know I didn't die okay
I had crystallized oh and now I'm a
glamazon created for the runway
[Music]
[Applause]